for an exclusive interview and we had to
protect their identities for their own
safety and listen to what they had to
say
I drove you here to speak to me today I
feel like our agents have been forgotten
I mean they're unsupported morale is low
they're being spread thin and I feel
like he basically put a Target on my
husband's back and all the agents back
really
by highlighting on truths and not
supporting them as an organization have
the agents all felt neglected since
President Biden has taken office is
there just a complete shift yes
yes explain what that's like as the wife
of an agent
I mean they feel powerless I feel
powerless
because my husband's trying to do
anything and everything he can to keep
the Border safe to keep us safe
and here is an Administration that has
made my husband and the rest of the
agents look powerless or people that are
breaking our laws the most amount of
problems that we've had in our home was
in the like the first couple of months
the first like six to eight months
within this administration because so
much changed so fast and there was
nothing the guys could do there was
anything our agents could do to change
that even if they brought it up they
were quickly turned down to say you
don't have you don't have a choice what
is your worst nightmare first of all our
husbands
um we know every single time that they
go to work there's a chance they're not
coming back
possibly right
we never know if this suicide going on
is going to affect them
so our husband's safety and and I'm sure
many of us here have have experienced
them getting hurt getting that call
um so it's nerve-wracking but at the
same rate knowing what's coming in I'm
scared for my kids because we do know
for a fact that there's traffickers that
there's cartel living here
and there are monsters
so that's scary just attending those
kids attending our kids schools
[Music]
that's a fact
car told kids attend the same high
schools our kids attend
I think what needs to be brought to
light is or be investigated is
individuals that are already in in the
position in the patrol like mallorcas
that are not stating the facts
unfortunately we do need to be bluntly
honest so we need to be real right
individuals like mallorca's that do a
severe cover-up job is not healthy for
the country
joining us now investigative reporter
Fox News contributor Sarah Carter so
under Joe Biden the first two years of
his presidency he's not enforcing the
laws of the land and that is the laws at
our border he's aiding and abetting in
the law breaking he's even given
preferential treatment to those entering
the country illegally no vaccine mandate
no covet Test free phones free
Transportation the American taxpayer on
the hook to supply you know food water
housing medicines and and education for
their kids
and the cartels are ruling and I can't
you hear the wives of these agents
they're putting their lives at risk
every day and it's frustrating because
the cartels are winning
absolutely Sean I mean it's
gut-wrenching to hear the wives talk to
talk to border patrol agents to know
that they don't have a voice these wives
are speaking out for their husbands and
for all the border patrol agents I can
tell you there were so many more because
they want to give a voice to their
husbands and they feel that the Biden
Administration has literally literally
thrown them under the bus is what they
one of the wives said to me uh you know
uh targeting them publicly uh the morale
is down one of the things that was
interesting to me Sean was the fact that
they were saying the hypocrisy of the
administration saying this is about
immigrants this this was brought to me
by the U.S Hispanic Business Council and
the women that I were speaking to some
of them were immigrants they had come
here and became legal citizens this is
about the men in illegally and this is
about the men and women of law
enforcement and our federal agents and
standing by their side and protecting
our nation and being undermined by their
president who should be enforcing the
law we'd all go to jail for human
trafficking all right thank you Sarah
for that great report hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else